who introduces me to mr. Paul king of
the tarantula hunters he's agreed to
take me to his favorite spider spot but
worryingly booth er has lead me to it do
they move very fast record I have erred
late they move fast
eight legs do you think they've moved
plenty fast there's a real art to
catching these hairy critters they live
in burrows deep in the jungle
besides that hole in there yeah for the
villagers selling tarantulas it's a
welcome source of extra cash there's
only one transfer in their cut they go
down deep don't they
he's gone it's gone so when I was young
especially in the time most people they
starvation so to fill the stomach we had
to eat all kind of insects even a snail
or lizard
18 out of necessity the Cambodians have
developed an insatiable appetite for
these eight-legged beasts oh that's a
massive hole
but see how got him is in there is where
Thanks
yeah so he's not gonna bite you now now
on that you can hear how strong the head
is ah now it's my turn
mr. Paul's discovered a really large
borough that promises a price specimen I
face some really tough challenges on my
travels normally this team down but
there's something about these big hairy
beasts that really gives me the willies
there dun-dun-dun let his head move so
he cannot turn the head Tobias was
amazed how strong the head was really
strong you're very strong Jesus Christ
is that big enough to eat yes sorry okay
I mean it feels really weird because
they're furry and absolutely disgusting
and now you're gonna tell me that it's
delicious yeah it's so full of the hope
in the belly
so really delicious this is insane
absolutely crazy
your boys are pissing themselves look at
that English no bed scared of a little
fairy spider
Yeah right okay let's take him off [ __ ]
catching these hairy beasts is one thing
now I've got to eat them